- Hi, everyone, Sal Khan here.
And I just wanted to tell you all
that we've reached kind of
several really cool milestones
at Khan Lab School,
which you can learn more
about at khanlabschool.org or kls.org.
A lot of folks are surprised to hear
that I started a physical
school back in 2014
when I'm so associated
with online learning.
But I've never viewed online
as somehow a replacement
for an in-person experience.
The dream has always been
that online can unlock
the physical experience.
It can allow students to learn
at a pace that is appropriate for them.
It could allow for mastery-based learning
where if you get an 80% on something,
you don't just get a C on your forehead
and your permanent transcript
and then you're expected
to learn the next concept
that builds on that 20% gap.
Instead, you're expected
to master the concept.
So you always have a strong foundation.
That we can unlock a situation when
human beings get to a classroom together,
both the students and the teachers,
they're able to interact with each other,
they're able to collaborate
with each other,
they're able to have Socratic
dialogues, have games.
They're able to do projects together.
We wanted to create a
reality where students
aren't just accountable
for their own gains
or their own progress
but also for each other,
that they're invested in each other,
that they are unusually collaborative.
We wanted to explore blurring the lines
between high school and college.
If kids are able to learn more,
be truly curious, be truly engaged.
Why can't they learn faster
than you would normally expect?
The middle schoolers can
learn high school concepts,
high school students can
learn college concepts
and get credit for it.
So that by the time they graduate,
they're already operating at a junior
or a senior level in college
and actually getting credit for it.
And so the milestone that we're at
is that we're actually now at
a full K through 12 school,
over 200 students, we have
our first graduates this year.
And you could imagine in the early days
a lot of people went,
well, these are all
interesting ideas, Sal,
but will this work?
And it's a lab school,
there's all sorts of stuff
that we're constantly trying.
But you know, when I look at
this year's graduating cohort,
I'm incredibly proud of them,
mainly for who they have
become as human beings,
but some of the traditional metrics
by which we measure students,
they're also crushing it,
I guess is the best way to say it,
which is really powerful to show that
you can create a learning experience
where kids are intrinsically curious.
They're intrinsically wanna
collaborate with each other
and just wanna learn more.
But as a by-product of
it, not as a goal of it,
they're able to do incredibly
well on standardized tests.
Our students are scoring on average
better on standardized tests
than some of the very top
universities in the country
or in the world.
They are getting in to
some of the top universities in the world
even though they don't have
traditional letter grades
because the universities
are seeing that the grades
of mastery based learning
are even more powerful
because it's a higher standards,
it's expecting that all students
really master the concepts.
We're deepening our partnership
with Foothill College
which is a local college in the area
to get the best of both worlds,
the high school experience
and the college experience.
And so they have some exciting things
that I can't announce it just
yet also on the capacity side.
And so that's why I'm
out here telling folks
normally we can only admit
a few folks every year,
but this year there might
be an opportunity for more.
So, if you're interested,
if you live in the San
Francisco Bay area in particular
within driving distance to Mountain View,
Palo Alto Los Altos, encourage
you to take a look at it.
And I'm happy to answer any questions
in the message board below
that you might have about Khan Lab School.
My kids go there, I teach
there, I work very closely
with the faculty and the
administration there.
And what's exciting about it for me,
is that not just creating a really
unique learning experience
for the students who attend,
but as a lab school, creating
a model that can be replicated
throughout the world.
So once again,
happy to answer any questions
that anyone might have.